let's simplify some of these expressions
so this first one is seven times the
quantity s plus nine plus two s so we
can distribute the seven because seven
is times the entire quantity s plus nine
so it's we want to distribute the seven
so it becomes seven times s which is 7s
plus 7 times 9 which is 63
and so that's this part right over here
and then we have the plus 2s plus 2s
well if i have 7s's
if i have 7s's and i'm going to add
another two s's to them i'm going to
have nine s's so you add those two parts
you get 9s and then you still have your
plus 63.
let's do this one over here negative 4
minus the quantity q minus 10 plus five
so what i'm going to do here so we can
get rid of this these parentheses is
distribute the negative sign this is
essentially multiplying both of these
terms times negative one you could view
that there's a negative one out here
then this part right over here becomes
negative 1 times q or negative times q
so it's negative q
negative q and negative 1 times negative
10 is positive 10 plus 10. so that's
that part right over there and we still
have this negative 4 out front and this
plus 5 afterwards so what can we do over
here so we can add all the non-q the
only q term here is this negative q so
i'll just rewrite it over here negative
q
and then we have all of our constant
terms we have negative four
plus ten
plus five so negative four plus ten is
six plus five is eleven
plus eleven negative q plus and the rest
of this adds up to eleven let's do this
one all right so we have negative seven
times the quantity i plus two so we can
distribute the negative seven
so this is going to be equal to negative
seven times i which is negative seven i
plus negative 7 times 2 which is
negative 14 or we could write plus
negative 14 or we could just write minus
we could just write minus 14. so that's
this part right over here
and then we have negative 2 so this is a
negative 2 times the quantity 2 plus i
so that's times 2 and then that's times
i so negative 2 times 2 is negative 4 so
it's negative 4. negative 2 times
positive i is negative 2i and now we can
add the i terms
we have negative 7i
and we have negative 2i negative 7i
minus 2i is negative 9i
negative 9i
and then negative 14 minus 4 those are
our constant terms that gives us
negative 18. negative 14 minus 4 is
negative 18 and we are done